[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le Sky Eco le
magazine qui vous raconte l'actualité
économique du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines nous partirons
à la rencontre de Pascal chapon
directeur du site aliexis highlandcourt
leader mondial de la gestion des fluides
la french tech Paris Saclay fait
désormais partie des 16 capitales French
tech nous verrons en quoi cela consiste
et enfin asmoder l'éditeur de jeux fait
une braderie dont les fonds seront
reversés à une association Guillaume
rata directeur marketing dasmodé nous
raconte sa démarche RSE
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Pascal chapon bienvenue
à Élancourt nous sommes sur le centre de
recherche et technologies d'aliexis sur
50 années je suis directeur de ce site
et aujourd'hui je vous présentais la
recherche et le développement que l'on
effectue dans le domaine de la gestion
des fluides et en particulier la gestion
de l'eau
[Musique]
nous sommes arrivés ici il y a un an en
2022 au départ nous sommes arrivés avec
30 chercheurs aujourd'hui nous sommes 60
personnes sur ce centre de recherche et
nous continuons à grandir avec un
nouveau bâtiment qui va être mis en
service à la fin de l'année
tout d'abord les matières en plastique
nous utilisons beaucoup de matières
plastiques et une expertise sur les
matières plastiques des expertises
mécaniques chimiques pour développer nos
produits nos produits sont des produits
dans le transport des fluides et en
particulier le transport des fluides
dans vos maisons les canalisations mais
aussi dans les villes telles que les
infrastructures ou dans l'industrie nous
avons également des produits dans le
domaine agricole hemin tu n'entrer
responsable simulation peut tout nous
expliquer ce que tu es en train de faire
l'assimilation ça nous permet de réduire
le temps au lieu de faire 300 prototypes
on fait 300 simulations finalement en
deux trois produits ça nous permet de
réduire le coût accélérer l'innovation
et d'avoir moins de impact sur
l'environnement
[Musique]
ici à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous
avons 12 nationalités pourquoi 51
Yvelines tout simplement parce que nous
avons la proximité de la région
parisienne mais aussi la proximité des
gares la proximité des aéroports ça nous
permet de recevoir nos clients à
l'international et nos partenaires à
l'international sur ce site en région
parisienne nous pouvons collaborer soit
avec des entreprises en recherche et
développement mais aussi avec des
centres de recherche sur le plateau de
Paris Saclay des centres universitaires
connus au niveau mondial puisque le
centre de Paris saclair représente 70
000 chercheurs et le troisième pôle
industriel au monde nous allons
maintenant vous présenter les
laboratoires de Alexis R&D
[Musique]
par exemple notre expert ici travaille
sur les biofilm ça veut dire les
bactéries qui se développent dans les
réseaux d'eau et on essaye justement de
chercher des solutions pour améliorer la
qualité microbiologique de l'eau ça me
plaît beaucoup d'être ici aussi parce
que du coup je suis à côté de Paris en
même temps que j'ai beaucoup de nature
et vraiment ça mais ça me permet de me
développer avec un grand contrat de
recherche
[Musique]
salut Vincent salut Pascal dis-moi sur
quoi tu travailles aujourd'hui là
actuellement je suis en train de
vérifier la processabilité donc la mise
en forme d'un nouveau PVC qui est un PVC
avec un impact environnemental plus
faible on peut bien le mettre en forme
pour pouvoir l'utiliser dans nos futurs
applications chez Aliexpress moi ça fait
5 mois que je suis chez Alexis et j'ai
décidé de déménager à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines parce que le
cadre me plaît tout simplement et parce
que je pouvais je peux venir en vélo au
travail donc ça permet de respecter mes
convictions écologiques et aussi de
faire du sport
ici nous allons être dans un mode
beaucoup plus open innovation en
travaillant avec des universités des
startups des centres de recherche privée
à côté de grandes sociétés comme Thales
ou Airbus ça donne de la visibilité et
aujourd'hui depuis que nous sommes
installés ici nous arrivons facilement à
attirer des talents pour des
publications de poste nous avons
régulièrement plus de 400 CD par poste
publié et ça c'est vraiment un avantage
d'être sur cette zone industrielle en
fait
[Musique]
la french Tech est une initiative qui a
été lancée par le gouvernement il y a 10
ans maintenant par le Ministère de
l'économie en vue d'aider les startups
françaises d'être plus visibles à
l'échelle nationale mais également à
l'international et surtout de leur
permettre d'accélérer leur croissance
nous la french Chuck Paris Saclay on
constitue un des réseaux de la French
tech et on couvre le territoire du 78 et
du 91
on a cette typologie de startup qui est
particulière qui sont les startups
deeptech alors la dictée qu'est-ce que
c'est ce sont les startups qui ont un
lien très fort avec les laboratoires en
effet ce sont des structures qui ont
besoin de développer pendant des mois
voire des années leur solution pour
pouvoir adresser le marché nous le
territoire de Paris Saclay on concentre
un grand nombre de ces start-up plus de
70% de ses 600 startups qui constituent
le territoire de Paris Saclay
notre rôle aujourd'hui c'est d'aider ces
startups pour pouvoir accéder à des
financements adaptés également à des
structures et des bâtiments adaptés et
surtout de leur permettre de recruter
plus facilement des talents
[Musique]
la fin de d'être devenu une capitale
French tech elle était jusqu'à leur une
communauté alors la force d'être une
capitale friends au plus proche du
gouvernement et de pouvoir adapter ou
proposer des solutions adaptées aux
start-up de son territoire la notre rôle
ça sera bien entendu de permettre au
gouvernement de proposer des initiatives
des programmes des financements pour ces
startups la diptèques qui sont fortement
reconnus sur notre territoire Paris
Saclay
[Musique]
on est capital aujourd'hui on est
évidemment plus visible au niveau du
ministère de l'Industrie et on a des
visites ministérielles maintenant et on
met en avant les startups sur des
thématiques identifiées ce qu'on a fait
déjà le 16 février avec le ministre de
l'Industrie
[Musique]
à partir de maintenant de 15h à 16h vous
avez moins 25% sur le ticket de caisse
total
profitez des jeux
[Musique]
cette journée c'est une opération de
déstockage de vie d'entrepôt en tout cas
c'est l'occasion de faire profiter à
tous les jours de la commune de jeux à
des prix réduits et on fait un appel au
volontariat dans les équipes pour venir
travailler aujourd'hui on doit être
entre 20 et 25 nous sommes venus donner
un coup de main sur cette opération
[Musique]
boucher car c'est une association qui
s'occupe des personnes à la retraite et
des personnes âgées plus généralement
qui vient leur apporter des repas ou qui
leur apportent du réconfort ou tous les
jours
[Musique]
dans les actions RSE on en a plusieurs
la plus significative est celle d'Access
plus c'est à dire c'est la création de
jeu ou le développement de jeux qui
permettent aux gens qui ont des troubles
cognitifs de pouvoir travailler la
mémoire travailler la vue travailler le
toucher l'appréhension et ainsi de suite
et puis ensuite on a un certain nombre
de stratégies RSE au niveau du
développement du produit au niveau de la
taille des produits afin de les réduire
de réduire l'empreinte carbone de
réduire le plastique
[Musique]
j'ai eu le papier à l'entrée comme quoi
c'était pour des bénéfices associations
et j'en profite en même temps grâce à ça
c'est une excellente nouvelle non je ne
savais pas je suis un spécialement pour
l'aspect des stockages parce que j'aime
bien tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
recycle et de seconde main donc l'idée
me plaît généralement et là je suis
encore plus motivé par le fait que ça
ira versé par une association
[Musique]